tens of thousands of protesters and
belarus have taken to the streets of
minsk
and other cities for a second sunday in
a row
they're demanding president alexander
lukashenko's resignation accusing him
of rigging elections two weeks ago
lukashenko who has ruled belarus for
26 years has accused nato of trying to
split up
belarus he's ordered the army to
mobilize
saying the country was at risk of
imminent attack
putting on a show of force belarus
president
alexander lukashenko told his military
commanders
to use the toughest measures possible to
protect the country
he claims enemies are at the border as
for opponents
inside he's threatened to close
factories if strikes against his regime
continue
but lukashenka's rule is drawing to an
end
so says exiled opposition leader
svetlana tikanovskaya
anyway even if we there
this movement will slow down or come
down a little bit
but our people
they will not accept our president
anymore we have changed
our minds have changed and we will not
be able to
be under this president anymore under
this authorities we will struggle
till our victory till
we will get the changes in our country
the struggle continued on saturday women
took a stand against the violent
repression of protests
ignoring official warnings
and more crowds gathered in central
minsk
staying into the night
we are many it's impossible to silence
to fire and to imprison
everyone if they jail 100 people 200
will protest tomorrow
because people can't stand this anymore
we've reached our limit
they have shaken off fear and set hopes
alight
a victory even if nothing else changes
from minsk i am joined by dw
correspondent
nick connolly on the telephone nick i'm
happy that we have a connection
what's going on there right now
good afternoon michael i'm staying just
off independence square the main square
here in minsk that is just a sea of
white and red protest flags
as you mentioned there no signal on the
square that's been a government tactic
in recent weeks cutting off mobile
internet to prevent
footage of all of this getting out but
you don't get a sense from people here
that they're really scared the police we
have some
police officers getting up with
megaphones telling people reminding them
that these protests were illegal that
taking part in these protests uh was an
illegal act and they were booed out you
didn't get any sense that anyone was
particularly scared of them
although protesters are sure that there
are um security service people in
civilian
clothes filming faces going through the
crowds trying to work out who
uh who is coordinating all of this but
it's that's the problem for the regime
right now these are mass protests that
seem to be
uncoordinated that are happening
spontaneously so it's not easy for the
regime to crack down on people
another interesting detail um we've seen
restrictions on access to mints today
roads
leading to the capital being either shut
or being restricted to
speeds documents being checked
unnecessarily as a way of trying to pull
down the count out
to become the turnout rather for this
demonstration but it doesn't seem to
have worked this is
a huge demonstration of something that
frankly would have been unthinkable in
belarus just a few months ago
nick spontaneous but certainly massive
we're seeing images of
just huge gatherings of what appear to
be pretty resolute people standing their
ground there the belarus's defense
minister viktor krenim
says authorities will deploy inments to
protect
monuments implying of course that they
would potentially use
the army against these demonstrators it
sounds to me nick as if the government's
tactic is to show a strong hand rather
than to comet citizens
well quite and this seems for now to
being counterproductive people are
outraged
the ones i've spoken to who've been
reading this news in the recent minutes
that this news only came out about an
hour ago
that indeed the army would now be
brought out onto the streets of minsk
essentially to face off against unarmed
protesters so far
only riot police um being used during
these protests
whether or not those soldiers will
really be willing to use force against
protesters is a big question we've
already
had reports of several members of
security services
either um taking sick leave or resigning
because they refuse
to participate in this but for now it
does seem like the
uh leadership of these countries are
still on elegant luxembourg's side
but these are very uh scary times here
in belarus
yeah situation in which the army would
be declared within the country is
unprecedented
but talking to people looking at them
you don't get the sense people are for
now
particularly with their personal safety
if only because of the big numbers
there's a feeling that
the regime can't arrest everyone who's
come out in recent weeks the numbers are
just too big
no doubt we'll be hearing more from nick
connolly from minsk as the day develops
nick
greatly appreciate it
you